now senator Harris says she's proud of  her record as a prosecutor and that  she'll be a prosecutor president but I'm  deeply concerned about this record there  are too many examples to cite but she  put over 1500 people in jail for  marijuana violations and then laughed  about it when she was asked if she ever  smoked marijuana  she blocked  [Applause]  would have freed an innocent man from  death row until the courts forced her to  do so she kept people in prison beyond  their sentences to use them as cheap  labor for the state of California and  she fought to keep the system in place  that impacts poor people in the worst  kind of way